[Musica]
pillola rossa o pillola blu pillola blu
Fine della storia domani ti sveglierai
nella tua camera e crederai a quello che
vorrai
pillola Rossa rimarrai nel Paese delle
Meraviglie E vedrai Quanto è profonda la
tana del Bianconiglio con queste parole
nel film Matrix Morfeo chiede a neo di
fare la sua scelta Eppure nonostante il
peso che possa avere c'è qualcosa di più
importante della natura di una decisione
da prendere più importante della scelta
che faremo è avere la possibilità di
scegliere
tutti i giorni siamo chiamati a fare
molteplici scelte il più delle volte le
facciamo volentieri ma qualche volta
onestamente ne faremo anche volentieri a
meno ma è proprio grazie alle scelte che
facciamo che riusciamo a riempire i
vuoti della nostra vita e se possono
rappresentare lo strumento Per colmare
le distanze del nostro mondo
Mi chiamo Walter di Francesco e no il
nome non l'ho scelto io e sono un
Mentalista Questa sì è stata una mia
scelta come è stata una mia scelta
quella di trattare un argomento come il
libero arbitrio un argomento
affascinante che tocca tutti eh
indistintamente del resto la possibilità
di fare una scelta libera Seguendo le
proprie volontà e una condizione
imprescindibile dell'essere umano e del
vivere civile
lo diceva anche Winston Churchill la
democrazia e la peggior forma di governo
eccezion fatta per tutte le altre e
dunque Viva le vibra scelte e già perché
noi non vorremmo che sia qualcun altro a
scegliere al posto nostro giusto a meno
che non si tratti del navigatore
satellitare anche se può capitare che il
dispositivo non sia aggiornato E vabbè
ci toccherà rimanere per 6 ore fermi in
tangenziale ma questa è un'altra storia
dicevo che il più delle volte siamo
consapevoli della necessità di dover
prendere una posizione in prima persona
e sappiamo che se non dovessimo
scegliere
rischieremo di fare la fine dell'asino
di Buridano che non riuscendo a
scegliere tra due mucchi di fini
identici muri di fame
Insomma quando la vita ci pone davanti a
delle Sliding Doors sempre per rimanere
alle citazioni cinematografiche possiamo
dire che generalmente Cerchiamo sempre
di fare la scelta migliore
sostenuti dalle nostre convinzioni
consci delle nostre capacità e
consapevoli delle conseguenze di ciò che
faremo
Che vestito mi metto meglio la lasagna o
gli spaghetti mi sposo oppure no i bevi
sono innumerevoli ma prendiamo il
classico tiro di rigore Il Cacciatore
deve decidere se tirarlo a destra oppure
a sinistra il portiere invece pure è la
scelta sembra essere libera e
consapevole per entrambi Ma le pressioni
possono essere enormi Magari il
rigorista e ne ha appena sbagliato un
recentemente e magari il portiere ne ha
appena parlato un recentemente e magari
entrambi sono a conoscenza di quanto è
accaduto all'altro e poi c'è la diretta
televisiva allo stadio stracolmo c'è un
tifo infernale Chissà forse c'è in palio
anche un trofeo molto prestigioso è
tutto questo potrebbe condizionarli Ma
alla fine il calciatore decide di tirare
a destra
ora non sempre nella nostra giornata ci
giochiamo una coppa del mondo ma sembra
sempre che esistono delle suggestioni in
grado di influenzarci possono essere
fattori biologici il nostro stato fisico
le nostre emozioni possono essere
fattori ambientali sociali culturali
cognitivi persino il bieco marketing
potrebbe suggestionarci in modo
determinante insomma anche quella che
pensavamo fosse una scelta assolutamente
indipendente e personale in realtà
potrebbe essere stata condizionata da
chissà quali elementi
c'è Chi sostiene che tutto sia regolato
da un Dio onnipotente che Tuttavia ci ha
concesso la libertà di scegliere e c'è
chi attribuisce al patrimonio genetico
tutto ciò che siamo e quindi tutto ciò
che Sceglieremo di fare anche se ad
esempio due gemelli identici con lo
stesso DNA Ma che vivono in contesti
diversi di fronte alla stessa situazione
possono fare scelte addirittura opposte
Insomma sembra di essere finiti in quel
famoso romanzo di heller comma 22
vittime della Diabolica regola che dice
Chi è pazzo può chiedere di essere
esonerato dalle missioni di volo Ma chi
chiede di essere esonerato dalle
missioni di volo non è pazzo e dunque
Dov'è finito il nostro libero arbitrio
un essere umano deve avere la
possibilità di fare le sue scelte
altrimenti Che senso avrebbe la sua vita
Socrate il grande filosofo greco pur
essendo stato condannato ingiustamente
Una volta finito in carcere rifiuta le
proposte di fuga dei suoi discepoli che
hanno organizzato la sua evasione
sceglie
di accettare la condanna perché dice è
meglio subire un'ingiustizia piuttosto
che commetterla è incredibile pensate
scegli Addirittura il tipo di esecuzione
che gli toccherà e decide di morire
avvelenato con la cicuta
disse
è venuta l'ora di andare io a morire Voi
invece a vivere ma chi tra noi abbia
scelto il meglio e oscuro a tutti con la
sua scelta guidato da uno scopo
superiore
Socrate affronta il più terribile degli
avversari
l'istinto di sopravvivenza il suo credo
sia l'esempio uno degli esempi più
potenti dell'esercizio del libero
arbitrio Se ci pensate una scelta
autonoma
indipendente
che nessuno ha saputo contrastare
né tantomeno prevedere ma ho detto
prevedere vi va di verificare un insieme
a me con un esperimento
lancerò tra di voi delle palline da ping
pong
Chi prenderà le palline mi bastano
almeno sei persone che dovranno Alzarsi
per alzarsi in piedi e giocherà con me
cerco di lanciarle in più meglio che si
può perfetto la signora attenzione a non
prenderla nell'occhio magari qualcuno
anche qua non c'è Ecco chi vuole
prendere la pallina la prenda pure Ecco
lì
Eccola perfetto il Signore Se volete
alzarvi vedo anche quante persone avete
Eccolo qua Perfetto ci sono 6 persone in
piedi Alzatevi che hai preso la pallina
1 2 3 4 ancora due palline vai
signore Ecco dietro al signore 5 si alzi
in piedi ti ha preso la pallina dietro
il Signore perché si alzi pure ancora
una pallina facciamo di là
OK signora Fantastico sei persone in
piedi le abbiamo
cortesemente si alzi 1 2 3 4 5 6
perfetto
ora
torno qua Partiamo dalla persona
cominciò Da sinistra verso destra sei
persone ma ne vedo 7 quindi qualcuno si
sieda Ok Perfetto Ottimo Adesso si
siedono tutti No a tornare alle palline
no eh mi raccomando sei sei sei sei sei
Va bene sei allora manca una persona uno
con la pallina si alzi sennò scendo lo
chiedo di alzarsi uno
eravate 8 prima
Brava signora vedevo Ok Allora comincio
con te ti chiedo di andare a immaginare
quello che andrò a suggerirti Ok
immagina di essere nella periferia di
una grande città
sta arrivando verso di te un pullman
questo pullman davanti sulla parte alta
ha un display quelli in quel display c'è
un numero e quel numero il numero alla
quale appartiene la linea di
quell'autobus
con la tua immaginazione
vedendo arrivare a questo pullman verso
di te che numero cibi di scritto Dimmi
un numero dall'1 al 90 17 17
scriviamo pure 17 17 + Anzi grazie Poi
che mi hai prestato il cellulare così
almeno avere un cellulare con un bel
display e 17 Il Signore è il suo
obiettivo è quello di salire su questo
pullman però purtroppo quando si aprono
le porte si accorge che è strapieno di
gente è impossibile salire secondo lei
questo pullman quante persone trasporta
52 52 più 52 più la signora
ovviamente è impossibile salire sul
pullman quindi siamo costretti a
prendere la nostra auto
si mette alla guida della sua auto Entra
in autostrada e mentre sta guidando il
suo sguardo va a finire sulle ultime due
cifre del suo contachilometri ma non i
contachilometri di oggi quelli digitali
quelli di una volta quelli con le
rotelline che giravano il suo sguardo va
a finire lì proprio mentre le due cifre
si stanno allineando che cifra vede mi
dica un numero dall'1 al 90 10 10 Più 10
più
perfetto la signora
da lì a poco le viene fame vede che c'è
un cartello che le indica che è vicino a
un centro commerciale
entra in questo centro commerciale ma
scopre che uno dei centri commerciali
tra i più grandi al mondo
la prima cosa che fa è andare a contare
quante casse ha il centro commerciale
tra i più grandi al mondo Quante casse
conta
65 65 + 65 +
il Signore
lei viene un po' di fame entra
all'interno del Centro Commerciale
prende uno snack va la cassa e paga a
questo punto la cassiera le chiede di
pagare il conto
che cifra le chiede la cassiera
4 euro e 19 perfetto 4 + 19 24 giusto
23 23 65 23 più 24 19 23 più
infine il Signore decide a questo punto
di recuperare la sua auto e si rende
conto che la sua auto è parcheggiata in
un parcheggio dove sono i posti numerati
dal 1 al 90 alcuni posti sono già
occupati 17 52 Il 10 il 65 e il 23 A
questo punto sale sull'auto fare
retromarcia è solo in quel momento
scopre la sua auto in Quale di questi 90
parcheggi era Parcheggiata Che numero
vede 33 33 più 33 esce 200 uscirà tutti
i 200 perché la matematica non è
un'opinione ma vorrei andare oltre per
voi e vi dica Ti vorrei chiedere un
piacere Ti posso chiedere adesso
facciamo più di andare a toccare in
maniera casuale dei tasti Guarda dove
sono più o meno i tasti tocca in maniera
casuale ok Per ora hai fatto 1 5 0
toccare ancora qualcuno
1 5 0 4 1 4 ancora un paio dai
1 5 0 4 1 4 2 9 corretto Ok quindi
scriviamo il numero che è appena scelto
tu più
[Musica]
15 milioni te lo da fuori di camera 15
milioni 041.429
41 4.29
adesso facciamo uguale
Ok uguale arriviamo a 15 milioni
041.629 15 milioni 041 629 un numero
assolutamente casuale ma forse così
casuale Non è perché basta magari
guardarlo da un'altra angolazione Ed
ecco che posso Grazie 15 milioni
41.629 ma anche 15 aprile alle 16 e 29 e
se non sbaglio è ora
[Applauso]
Grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie mille davvero Grazie anche del
telefono Eh dopo te lo do
è perfetto ma torniamo per un secondo
sui sei numeri che avete scelto i numeri
li avete scelti voi è corretto in
maniera assolutamente libera ma quando
siamo portati a scegliere dei numeri
magari quella volta che siamo
in cielo possa cambiarci la vita tipo un
gioco tipo quello Tipo il SuperEnalotto
Voi sapete Quante combinazioni ci sono
per vincere a questo gioco una su oltre
620 milioni per darvi l'idea della
grandezza di questo numero vi chiedo di
immaginare 900 camion di quelli da
cantiere Avete presente quelli col
cassone che di solito trasportano terra
grandi 900 camion in fila quindi una
fila chilometrica di questi camion che
arriva arrivano insieme all'interno
dello stadio di Fermo Ognuno di questi
camion il proprio cassone trasporta
700.000 palline da ping pong
700.000 per ogni cassone sono 900
cassoni quindi noi arriviamo all'interno
dello stadio ci troviamo davanti una
montagna immensa di palline da ping pong
poi arrivo io né coloro solamente una di
rossa e la metto insieme alle altre
Dopodiché tutti voi vi bendate entrate
bendate in questa montagna di palline da
ping pong e al buio prenderete
all'interno del vostro pugno una sola
pallina Dopodiché dovete immaginare di
uscire da questa montagna togliervi la
benda aprire la mano e Scoprire di aver
preso la pallina Rossa facile No ora
qualche volta gioco anche io Questo
gioco è tipo questa mattina sono stato
in Piazza Dante a Fermo con un
responsabile del Ted che mi ha
accompagnato e insieme abbiamo giocato
una schedina io la mia schedina ce l'ho
qua e ve la faccio vedere
ovviamente dopo pubblicheremo anche la
foto della schedina perché abbiamo i
testimoni e questi sono i numeri che
avete scelto voi 17 52 10 65 23 33 e qua
ci sono i numeri che abbiamo giocato Noi
questa mattina a Fermo nella tabaccheria
di Piazza Dante e ve li faccio vedere
vedo anche a favore di camera Spero che
si possano vedere vediamo se si può
inquadrare la schedina
e se vedete c'è esattamente il 10 il 17
il 23 il 33 il 52 e il 65 e un po' come
se tutto il Ted in qualche modo oggi
avesse vinto un gioco impossibile il
SuperEnalotto tutto quello che avete
visto è reale ma quanto è reale la
realtà
decidetelo voi io la mia scelta l'ho
fatta
adesso
tocca a voi fare la vostra grazie
[Applauso]